- All right, we are back.
(audience applause)
And as you know, it's the start
of Hispanic heritage month
this hour and throughout
all of September and October
we are shining the light on
ways the Hispanic community
makes our country richer.
So, I wanna tell you about
one little Afro-Latina girl
here in New York city
who is developing a powerful
voice as a journalist.
At 12 years old
she's already landed interviews
with some of the biggest
names in pop culture.
Everyone from Usher to Tom Holland,
- [Kelly] from Mary J.
Blige to AOC, even Jay-Z.
(audience applause and cheers)
It's crazy. Check Jazzy
out in action y'all
- Hey guys, it's Jazzy
and I'm here in York city
and we're about to
interview Mr. Sean Carter
To all the kids who have dreams
of being successful like you
What advice could you give them?
- Being successful like me?
Okay. Believe in yourself.
Even for anyone else believes in you.
You're very confident.
- Thank You.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience applause)
- Jazzy's got quite a growing fan base
with more than 60,000 subscribers
on her YouTube channel, Jazzy World TV
and about 200,000 followers on Instagram.
(mimics trumpet sound)
(audience laughing)
We have her joining us now.
So give it up
(audience cheers)
- for Jazzy.
(audience applause and cheers)
- It's so great to meet you.
I'm honored to meet you.
That is a pretty great
get when you get Jay-Z
I'm just saying, were you freaking out?
- I was really nervous at the time.
I was really excited
too, but first of all,
Jay-Z, he's a big inspiration to me
And so many other kids around the world.
I mean, he's extremely successful
and we're from similar neighborhoods.
Shout out to Brooklyn, by the way.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] I love you so much.
- [Kelly] Oh my God
(Kelly giggles)
- But I'm very grateful
for the opportunity I had
to meet him and it really
helped boost up my platform.
Here I am now. I mean, I
wouldn't be here without you.
(audience cheers)
- I love that.
And it probably helped
give you confidence.
- Right
- Yeah
- it definitely did give me confidence.
I mean, it was just an
amazing time. I loved it.
(audience applause)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So wait, so what's
what's your long term
goal in the industry?
What do you wanna do?
- Well, I want to continue to
I want to continue to help
inspire people to be great.
And, I wanna have my own talk show.
- Okay.
- I mean, I want people to know
that kids also have
voices that matter too.
- Yeah.
- Also, I don't see many journalists on TV
that look like me.
So, representation is
definitely very important.
(audience cheers)
- Absolutely.
- And when I say
- and you could be that.
- Yeah.
- When I say that, I mean,
people like Taylor Brooks
um, Angie Martinez.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The queen, Oprah Winfrey.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Angie
- [Kelly] Never heard of her.
(audience laughing)
- Never
Who?
(Kelly laughs)
- No, I love that, and
I happen to know someone
who's a giant fan of Jazzy's work
and we know Jazzy's a fan of her.
So, she's a broadcaster
who is also kind of known
as the voice of New York.
I think you might know
who I'm talking about.
And we consider her a
whole lot of woman, y'all
(upbeat music)
- Say hello, Jazzy, to Angie Martinez!
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music drowns out speaker)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Oh my gosh.
- I love you so much.
- Thank you.
(audience laughing)
- [Angie] You are the, I'm
sorry, this is your show, you go
- [Kelly] Go, no, go go.
(Angie laughing)
- You are the cutest, most vibrant
most lovely little thing I
have seen in such a long time.
I'm so happy to meet you.
- So happy to meet you too.
(audience applause)
I'm so, thank you so much.
I always wanted to interview you
and like you're such a big
- You did?
- inspiration and just, oh my God.
I can't believe I'm here with you.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God! Well, I'm here for you, love.
If for any type of like
advice, mentorship,
I definitely wanna spend time with you.
If you'd like to come to come
hang out with me on my show
I will show you everything
that goes on there.
You wanna come by when
I'm shooting my podcast
come on over. I will, I will
tell you everything that I know
and help kind of push you along.
If that helps you in any way.
I, I am here. I'm here for
you in any way you need me.
(audience applause and cheers)
- Thank you so much
- Oh my God. I can't wait to see
what, well, what you do next year.
I don't, You don't even need to grow up.
You're already doing it.
(audience laughing)
(Angie laughing)